welcome to this video plane jave off
from France in a 15-minute game game
game game game game what would we got
here hmm gruenfelder Kings Indian not
same moon thought yeah I'm always
tempted by this age for stuff let's do
that always disappointed if they okay if
they go on c6 but he didn't tip late age
five yeah here there is more than one
interesting way to play there is there
is just taking any form somehow claiming
that inserting the H pawns have
benefited wide the other interesting
this Bishop g5 after which then the
normal response 94 is completely useless
because I take on d5 on this is totally
different of course to them normal
Bishop g5 line interesting yeah now I
can actually take here and take the five
there are there are of course Paul
sacrifices like that and the gruene
fault okay Wow
a bit shocked I thought he would at
least try to activate the bishops um
okay I'll take that yeah hmm the
question is should I even react to that
I can oops sorry the point is after cd5
their screen b3 and some I'm just
attacking d 5 which is a bit difficult
to protect maybe just bishop e6 queen
bee 797 but yeah there is some there is
some development
hmm not totally sure that this is so
great for me because I lose lots of time
okay so it's not going for that I can
take on d5 with the Queen now and I
probably should I mean that's the only
real justification for the whole thing
okay let's do that night x would have
run into Bishop b6 you know queen bee
hive is the response here yeah I guess
so
yeah that all looks some pretty weird
for for black but do not forget he's got
he's got the two bishops and he will
gain some time on my queen so it's not
it's not an automatic win back where
they for maybe at the end i bethought
really need to go to the one but i
thought i can take this now it's really
ignoring my moves where is there some
big idea I don't think so I just I just
can take it
jump very difficult now I mean the
problem is I ate eggs b5 Queen a8 is
really really no compensation whatsoever
I'm just grabbing the material and there
is nothing and I'm by taking cdc6 now
with the bishop so what else is there
we're treating the knight to e7 that
looks really miserable yeah it seems
that h4 really count cotton on the wrong
foot entirely yeah this line is really
am it's really very dangerous against an
unpaired designs player yeah resigned
very early but the thing is after this
Bishop chief after this age for him h5
is really not a good move I mean it
really isn't due to various reasons you
can also argue that this is probably
quite good for white as well blacks
Kings side is in general a bit of an
issue in the green fault and here this
age five move to start really does not
really help in various scenarios I guess
this is a problem let's say in the root
be one line I mean I'm not not saying I
don't know it really I don't know any
concrete theory but here it could be
very tricky to have her age five plate
just one example but this Bishop g5 is
also not bad because well it asked like
how I going to defend your d5 pawn he
can play c6 but this is in a way a bit
passive and I can take on d5 for
instance and play queen bee three
something like that should be a bit
better for wide and all 94 the normal
response to Bishop g5 without the h
pawns played at here yeah I can just
take it out 95 or is this maybe this is
this is a playable pants
if you think of it maybe you can do that
and now c5 this is may be playable may
be playable for black but I will wait on
e6 always have 9 f 6 mm interesting
maybe I can can just continue like that
I did I don't know I mean I only have a
vague idea about this age for line but
it's always leading to interesting play
yeah here I think Bishop takes this is
so certainly interesting to to check
takes and after that black you should
probably play c6 or maybe c5 this kind
of moves they are they are interesting
still something like that getting this
and this Bishop will always be very
strong on the long diagonal but this is
just not playable I think and it just
gives up the porn and I can even take
the six year but this wasn't too bad as
wrong I thought that maybe this was an
idea I cannot really take d5 now this is
not working now they had too much
development cannot do that so oops sorry
I was till it was too too many moves
back i need to somehow negotiate the
Queen retweet something like that maybe
going back and black has some some wake
wake compensation maybe however the
computer points of this move which is
pretty strong actually yeah it is not
enough it's not enough for the pond but
something like that you probably should
have tried alright thanks for watching